>>> OKAY, EVERYBODY, YOU'RE IN
FOR A TREAT.
FANS OF THE HIT HBO SHOW
"SUCCESSION" KNOW HIM AS LOGAN
ROY.
ACTOR BRYAN COX GIVES US A
BRUTALLY HONEST ASSESSMENT OF
HOLLYWOOD IN HIS NEW MEMOIR
"PUTTING THE RABBIT IN THE HAT."
WE CAN TELL YOU THERE ARE PLENTY
OF FAMOUS NAMES MENTIONED, FOR
BETTER OR WORSE, WE SHOULD NOTE,
AS WELL AS BEHIND THE SCENES
STORIES FROM THE SHOW THAT HAS
MADE HIM A HOUSEHOLD NAME.
>> BORE ON THE FLOOR.
BORE ON THE FLOOR.
BRING THE TROOPS.
ON THE FLOOR, BORE.
>> COME ON, FRANK.
>> HOW THE [ BLEEP ] WOULD I
KNOW, GREG?
DO YOU THINK I HAVE AN
EXPLANATION FOR THIS?
>> THE PIGGIES GUEST OF HONOR.
OINK FOR YOUR SAUSAGES, PIGGIES.
NO HALF-HEARTED OINK.
>> NOT DOING IT.
>> THE LAST PIGGY TO EAT A
SAUSAGE IS THE MOLE.
>> THAT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE A VERY
GOOD SYSTEM.
>> HILARIOUS AND DISTURBING AT
THE SAME TIME.
THE GREAT ACTOR BRYAN COX JOINS
ME NOW.
"SUCCESSION" STREAMS ON HBO MAX
WHICH IS OWNED BY THE SAME
PARENT COMPANY AS CNN.
BRIAN, WHEN THE SHOW FIRST
STARTED, IT WAS BASED ON RUPERT
MURDOCH BUT AS IT WENT ON, THERE
ARE NODS TO JEFF BEZOS, ELON
MUSK, AND THE TRUMP FAMILY.
IT'S ABOUT ENTITLEMENT.
EXPLAIN THAT TO US.
>> THE PROBLEM IS THIS LOSS OF
REALITY PEOPLE HAVE WHEN THEY
ARE ENTITLED.
THERE ARE A FEW EXCEPTIONS, OF
COURSE.
BUT SEEMINGLY THERE'S A KIND OF
CONTINUING THING OF GOING ON.
WE SEE THE SAME IN MY COUNTRY
WITH PRINCE ANDREW AND HIS --
NOW HE'S ASKING FOR HIS TEDDY
BEARS TO BE COUNTED EVERY NIGHT
BEFORE HE WENT TO BED.
IT'S JUST RIDICULOUS.
IT REALLY IS RIDICULOUS.
THESE PEOPLE ARE SO SPOILED BY
THEIR WEALTH, AND THEY LOSE A
SENSE OF REALITY AND A SENSE OF
WHERE THEY'RE COMING FROM.
AND IT'S DEEPLY UPSETTING AND
ALSO VERY FUNNY.
>> IS IT THE TRUMP FAMILY THAT
WE'RE SEEING?
IS IT THE MURDOCH FAMILY THAT
IS IT A COMBINATION OF A BUNCH
OF DIFFERENT FAMILIES THAT THE
WRITERS ARE HAVING SOME FUN
WITH?
>> WELL, YEAH, I THINK THEY ARE
INFLUENCES, OF COURSE.
BUT IT'S THE ROY FAMILY, REALLY,
IS THE PRINCIPLE.
THEY ARE A CREATED ENTITY.
THEY ARE A DIFFERENT THING.
THEY'RE CERTAINLY NOT AS STUPID
AS THE TRUMPS, THEY'RE A LITTLE
MORE INTELLIGENT, I THINK.
SO THERE'S A SORT OF -- BUT, YOU
KNOW, THERE ARE CROSSOVERS, I
CAN SEE THAT.
AND NATURALLY AUDIENCES WILL
MAKE THOSE CONNECTIONS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND YOU HAVE PLAYED SOME
MAGNIFICENT ROLES, FOLKS SHOULD
KNOW, THE ORIGINAL HANNIBAL
LECTER IN "MANHUNTER," WHICH IS
A MASTERPIECE.
YOU ALSO WRITE ABOUT THE CURSE
OF BRIAN COX.
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THAT?
>> THE CURSE OF BRIAN COX IS
THIS THING OF I'VE BEEN TOO LATE
TO THE PARTY, IN A WAY.
YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S ALWAYS PROBLEMATIC,
ESPECIALLY WHERE WE ARE NOW,
WHICH IS OSCAR SEASON, OSCAR
SEASON KIND OF GOES ON FROM
REALLY -- I MEAN, IT SHOULD BE
BASED ON THE YEAR'S WORK, BUT IT
NEVER IS BASED ON THE YEAR'S
WORK.
WHAT IT'S BASED ON IS THE WORK
FROM THANKSGIVING TO CHRISTMAS.
AND IF A FILM GETS INTO
THANKSGIVING AND CHRISTMAS, YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE A CHANCE BUT IF
YOUR FILM COMES OUT BEFORE THEN,
FORGET IT.
AND I'VE BEEN SUBJECT TO THE
BRIAN COX CURSE, AN EXAMPLE IS
"CHURCHILL," I PLAYED CHURCHILL
AND IT ALL CAME OUT IN JUNE BUT
BY THE TIME THE OTHER FILM CAME
ALONG -- BUT I MEAN, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S PART OF WHAT THIS
BUSINESS DOES AND YOU GET USED
TO IT, ESPECIALLY AFTER 50
YEARS -- ACTUALLY NEARLY 60
YEARS NOW.
I'M SORT OF IMMUNE TO IT,
REALLY.
>> IT'S BEEN AN AMAZING CAREER,
AND SO MUCH OF IT IS JUST SO
APPARENT IN EVERY PAGE THAT YOU
WRITE IN THIS BOOK.
I DON'T NEED TO TELL YOU, YOU'VE
GOTTEN QUITE A BIT OF PRESS NOT
JUST FOR THE STORIES THAT YOU
TELL BUT THE UNABASHED CONTINUES
YOU GIVE ON SELECTS.
YOU SAY OF STEVEN SAGAL, AND I
HAD TO LAUGH AT THIS, HE IS AS
LUDICROUS IN REAL LIFE AS HE
APPEARS ONSCREEN, HE RADIATES A
STUDIED SERENITY AS THOUGH HE'S
ON A HIGHER PLANE THAN THE REST
OF US, AND ALTHOUGH IT'S A
DIFFERENT PLANE, IT'S PROBABLY
NOT A HIGHER ONE.
AND ABOUT JOHNNY DEPP, WHEN YOU
COME ON WITH MAKEUP LIKE THAT,
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO ANYTHING.
YOU ALSO GIVE IT TO QUENTIN
TARANTINO, KEVIN SPACEY.
NO SACRED COWS IN THIS BOOK.
>> NO, NO SACRED COWS.
BUT I'M A BIT TOO QUICK
SOMETIMES FOR MY OWN GOOD.
I'LL GO FOR THE LAUGHS
SOMETIMES.
THERE'S AN ADDENDUM WHICH I PUT
EVERYTHING IN PERSPECTIVE.
WHEN I SAY -- I THINK I SAID
THAT JOHNNY DEPP IS OVERRATED.
I MEAN, I THINK JOHNNY DEPP IS A
VERY GOOD ACTOR, DON'T GET ME
WRONG, I DON'T DISLIKE HIS
ACTING BUT HE HIMSELF WOULD
PROBABLY ADMIT HE FEELS HE'S
OVERRATED.
HE'S QUITE A SHY PERSONALITY.
I DO THINK WHAT HAPPENS TO A LOT
OF ACTORS, A LOT OF THINGS GET
PROJECTED ONTO THEM WHICH IS
SOMETIMES A BIT OF A BURDEN.
AND I SUSPECT THAT THAT'S A
BURDEN FOR HIM.
I DON'T KNOW THE MAN.
I DON'T DISLIKE HIS WORK, I'VE
SEEN SOME OF IT, IT'S EXCELLENT.
BUT I DO FEEL THAT'S WHAT HE
SUFFERS FROM.
>> AND TURNING BACK TO
"SUCCESSION," THE SEASON, THIS
SEASON WE SAW YOUR CHARACTER
LOGAN ROY ESSENTIALLY PICKING
THE GOP NOMINEE FOR PRESIDENT
BASED ON THE POWER HE WIELDS AS
HEAD OF A RIGHT WING MEDIA
EMPIRE.
IF DONALD TRUMP ENTERED THAT
FICTIONAL WORLD, HOW DO YOU
THINK HE WOULD HAVE FARED WITH
LOGAN?
>> HOW HE WOULD HAVE FARED WITH
I DON'T THINK LOGAN WOULD HAVE
MUCH RESPECT FOR DONALD TRUMP.
I THINK THAT HE WOULD THINK
THERE'S AN ELEMENT OF SHAM ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP.
AND I THINK LOGAN WOULD SEE
THROUGH THAT SHAM AND THEREFORE
HE WOULD NOT TAKE HIM VERY
SERIOUSLY.
AND CERTAINLY IF HE WAS AROUND
DURING HIS LAST PRESIDENCY, HE
WOULDN'T TAKE HIM AT ALL
SERIOUSLY.
SO LOGAN IS NOT AN IDIOT, HE IS
QUITE A SMART COOKIE.
AND ALSO HE STRADDLES TWO
CULTURES.
HE STRADDLES A UK CULTURE AND
THE AMERICAN CULTURE.
SO HE HAS A SENSE OF THE WORLD
WHICH IS -- HE'S AN MISANTHROPE,
HE'S MISERABLE AS HELL.
BUT HE'S A LITTLE MORE
INTELLIGENT THAN THE EX-POTUS.
>> THAT'S APPARENT.
BRIAN, YOU MADE HEADLINES FOR
SAYING THAT YOUR CAST MATE
JEREMY STRONG, QUOTE, GENUINELY
SUFFERS WHILE METHOD ACTING AS
YOUR SON KENDALL ROY ON
"SUCCESSION."
WHAT IS IT LIKE ON THE SET
PLAYING THESE INTENSE,
DYSFUNCTIONAL CHARACTERS FOR
HOURS AT A TIME?
I CAN UNDERSTAND WHY YOU WOULD
SAY THAT ABOUT YOUR FELLOW CAST
MEMBERS, BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE
WATCHING, IT IS DISTURBING TO
SLIP INTO THIS WORLD.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
AND I THINK KENDALL IS A
PARTICULARLY DISTURBED
CHARACTER.
AND HE GETS MORE AND MORE
DISTURBED AS THE SHOW HAS GONE
ON.
AND I THINK, YOU KNOW, IT'S VERY
HEADY PLAYING SOMEBODY LIKE
KENDALL.
YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE -- AND AGAIN,
JEREMY -- DON'T GET ME WRONG,
JEREMY DOES THE JOB, HE'S
EXCELLENT.
WE GET ON VERY WELL.
OUR WORK TOGETHER IS ALWAYS VERY
FINE.
THE SCENE, LIKE THE SCENE WE
HAD, THE DINNER SCENE AT THE
END, HE'S GREAT TO PLAY WITH,
REALLY.
BUT I DO WORRY ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THIS KIND OF SINKING
YOURSELF INTO THE ROLE TO SUCH
AN EXTENT, IT'S DANGEROUS, YOU
KNOW, YOU'VE GOT TO BE CAREFUL.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE VERY, VERY
CAREFUL WITH ACTING.
IT'S REALLY INTERESTING TO ME
THAT DANIEL DAY-LEWIS RETIRED AT
THE AGE OF 55.
WELL, I'M 75 AND I HAVE NO
INTENTION OF RETIRING.
BUT I THINK IF I HAD LIVED THE
LIFE THAT DANIEL HAD LIVED AND
DONE IT THE WAY HE HAD DONE IT,
I MIGHT HAVE RETIRED AT 55 AS
WELL, FROM SHEER EXHAUSTION.
>> NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
AND YOU SEE STORIES FROM TIME TO
TIME ABOUT ACTORS WHO PLUNGE TOO
FAR INTO THEIR ROLES AND IT CAN
TAKE A TOLL.
WE HAVE TO ASK YOU THIS
QUESTION, IT IS THE BILLION
DOLLAR LOGAN ROY QUESTION AT THE
HEART OF "SUCCESSION."
WHICH CHILD SHOULD LOGAN ROY
HAND THE COMPANY OVER TO?
I CAN'T IMAGINE IT BEING CONNOR,
BUT MAYBE SHIV.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> WELL, I THOUGHT IT WAS GOING
TO BE SHIV.
I REALLY DID THINK FOR A LONG
TIME IT WAS GOING TO BE SHIV.
BUT THEN SHIV CAN'T KEEP HER
MOUTH SHOT.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS YOU
HAVE TO DO, IS KEEP EVERYTHING
CLOSE, YOU CAN'T SHARE TOO MUCH.
I ALSO THOUGHT THAT ROMAN WAS IN
WITH A CHANCE BUT THEN HE'S GOT
THIS POTTY MOUTH THAT GETS HIM
INTO --
>> YES,